четыре фразы с немыслимой силой и
энергией слова способные изменить вашу
жизнь Я искренне считаю что эти фразы
реально могут перевернуть всю вашу жизнь
Если вы будете повторять их себе каждый
день первая фраза которую Я рекомендую
повторять вам каждый день я пришёл в
этот мир не зря эта фраза заставляет вас
искать свою миссию своё предназначение
эта фраза заставляет вас искать точку
максимального приложения усилий Дело в
том что без этой фразы вы будете
чувствовать себя человеком не
привязанным ни к чему который просто
как флигель на
ветру качается в зависимости от ветра вы
сами должны начать формировать свою
жизнь Вы не должны быть в плену у
событий вы сами должны начать
формировать события которые будут
происходить вокруг вас а для этого вам
нужно чётко понимать Для чего вы пришли
в этот мир у китайцев есть хорошая
поговорка у
корабля цели не бывает попутного ветра
так вот для того чтобы вся ваша жизнь
была эффективной нужно чётко понимать
Для чего вы пришли в этот мир ещё
Альберт Эйнштейн хорошую фразу сказал не
стремитесь быть успешными стремитесь к
тому чтобы ваша жизнь имела смысл
Поэтому вот эта фраза Я пришёл в этот
мир не зря она является спусковым
крючком который запускает ваш внутренний
поиск ответа вопрос А для чего я живу
для чего Вот это всё для чего мне деньги
для чего мне бизнес для чего вообще вся
моя деятельность и когда вы встанете на
этот путь вы закончите этот путь тем что
вы придёте к необходимости определения
своей миссии точки приложения усилий и
фокусирования именно на этом а это
максимально распакуй все ваши таланты
это максимально будет использовать все
ваши способности и ве весь ваш
темперамент для выполнения только одного
Дела Дело вашей миссии Поверьте мне это
приведёт вас к фантастическим
результатом вот когда меня спрашивают
всю ли я жизнь занимался саморазвитием и
размышлениями А я отвечаю Нет я жил
обычной жизнью в селе закончил сельскую
казахскую школу и после окончани школы
пошёл работать Чабанов и Многие знают
эту историю Однажды в знойный день я
Баранов смотрел на степь там поднималась
мариво и меня остро пронзила мысль
Неужели я пришёл в этот мир для того
чтобы пасти свою еду и вот эта одна
мысль как камень пущенный с горы вызвала
камнепад Я с тех пор ни разу не
останавливался И всего того что я достиг
сегодня всё это является результатом
того первого камня поэтому каждое утро
начинайте с фразы я не зря пришёл в этот
мир есть вопрос наверняка многие люди
возразить услышав такую мысль что Ну вот
скажут А вот если каждый так задумается
то в мире не останется
дворников
сантехников Столяров простых каждый
будет думать Великой мыслью и бросить
свою работу кто тогда будет нам вот полы
мыть и стуль чинить Многие люди считают
что миссия - это что-то такое высокое
возвышенное которое присуще только
крупным фигурам типа дала мы Нельсона
Манделы и так далее Нет на самом деле
миссия - это служение это смысл всей
вашей жизни расскажу вам притчу Однажды
монах с учеником шёл мимо церкви и
спросил у строителя который занимался
ремонтом этой церкви Чем ты занимаешься
на Что строитель сказал да Вот я беру
бетон смешиваю кладу и кладу на стену и
таким образом я как бы штукатур стену
монах с учеником двигаются дальше И
встретили на пути дворника и монах задал
тот же самый вопрос дворнику Чем ты
занимаешься На что дворник ему ответил Я
каждый день чищу дорогу к храму он мог
сказать я подметаю мусор но он сказал я
каждый день чищу дорогу к храму Так что
миссия - это не обязательно про что-то
высокое
заоблачной - это про то как вы
относитесь к тем делам которыми вы
занимаетесь одно дело вы можете
заниматься
рутины делами и думать это вообще никому
не нужно другое дело когда вы любому
своему действию приписывать
одухотворенность и приписывает высокое
значение За каждым простым делом стоит
великое дело вторая сильная фраза
которая может изменить вашу жизнь и
которую каждый день каждое утро Вы
должны повторять себе звучит так Мир
полон чудес проблема многих людей в том
что особенно атеистов в том что они
говорят сначала Покажите мне чудеса
потом Я поверю в них а на самом деле Мир
устроен иначе Сначала вы должны поверить
А после этого с Вами будут случаться
чудеса чудеса Что такое чудеса основная
особенность чудес в том что они приходят
Именно тогда когда они вам нужны и
именно в тот момент когда все шансы
говорят что это невозможно Именно
поэтому они и чудеса Когда вы каждое
утро себе говорите что мир чудес вы
открываете окно возможностей вы
открываете окно через которое в вашу
жизнь проникают чудеса вот я несмотря на
всю свою системность технично и так
далее Я пускаю И вообще определяю
чудесам огромную роль в своей жизни
потому что в моей жизни случилось так
много чудес что для меня это является
такой же истиной как любые законы физики
очень важно обращать внимание на знаки и
очень важно верить в чудеса вот когда с
вами случаются чудеса люди которые не
ведают не знают они говорят вам просто
повезло так вот что такое везение
смотрите как люди рассуждают Они
рассуждают с точки зрения законов теории
вероятностей так вот я не живу в мире
теории вероятност Я живу в мире чудес а
чудеса случаются Вопреки всем
вероятностям и здесь очень важно
понимать такую вещь что такое везение
вот в моём определени
везение - это благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств Это то что в просто народе
говорится он оказался в нужное время в
нужном месте но оказаться в нужное время
и в нужном месте разве это не чудо
поэтому вторая фраза которая которую вы
должны каждое утро себе повторять и
просто сделать частью своего ДНК звучит
так Мир полон чудес Верьте в это и да
будет вами чудеса я уверен в жизни
каждого из вас случались чудеса Просто
вы это относили к случаям каким-то
благоприятным случаем или мне повезло
Обычно люди говорят есть такая фраза
которая мне нравится она звучит так что
люди называют счастливым случаем то
а ту ситуацию когда не ведают А что
творит Всевышний на самом деле это
Всевышний Нам всё устраивает поэтому мы
не можем объяснить как это происходит
поэтому мы просто всё говорим а это
просто случай на самом деле у случаев
тоже есть своя закономерность Напишите
пожалуйста в комментариях все случаи
когда с вами происходили чудеса прямо
Напишите и заметьте такую вещь что они
всегда приходили к вам именно тогда
когда они нужны были вам и второе они
всегда приходили вам тогда когда на это
были минимальные шансы Поэтому всегда
оставляйте поле для чудес Напишите
пожалуйста в комментариях мы почитаем
Будет очень интересно и почитайте Что
случилось в жизни других людей и вы
поймёте что это является такой же частью
нашей реальности как и всё материально
третья фраза о которой я сегодня вам
хотел бы рассказать и которая
кардинально Может поменять вашу жизнь то
что с вами случится зависит не от ваших
целей зависит от ваших намерений Дело в
том что Всевышний судит нас людей по
намерениям в исламе говорится что если
человек задумал плохое дело но не сделал
ему записывается как одно хорошее дело
если человек задумал хорошее дело но не
сделал ему записывается как одно хорошее
дело а если человек задумал хорошее дело
и сделал Его то ему считается от семи и
до 700 хороших дел так вот Всевышний
судит нас по намерениям а люди судят
друг друга по делам вот в этом Большая
разница Поэтому до тех пор пока вы
глубоко не осознаете не поймёте что с
вами случается только то не то что вы
ставите целью а то что является вашим
намерением вам будет тяжело в этой жизни
поэтому Запомните эту фразу Например у
казахов Есть такое
выражение то есть сначала Исправь своё
намерение у узбеков и у казахов Есть
такое выражение жах ррс то есть хорошее
намерение половина богатства почему так
говорится потому что вот в одном
Посмотрите в моём видео я рассказываю
про то что про силу намерения и как оно
работает и про силу внешних сил смотрите
когда вы сидите на диване
и сделали хорошее намерение уже этот мир
бежит навстречу вам уже в этом мире всё
складывается в вашу пользу и на самом
деле просто даже себе сделав хорошее
намерение вы сделали так что на 50%
А мир уже для вас приготовил Сюрпризов
Вы ещё на диване сидите А уже кто-то там
думает или готов вам предложить какую-то
какую-то сделку или может быть в это же
самое время уже стучится какой-нибудь
курьер который Вам передаёт передаст
какой-то письмо и Ну вы не видите что
происходит в этом мире поэтому само
правильное намерение уже запускает
механизм работы внешних сил в вашу
пользу Потому что Всевышний на вашей
стороне четвёртая очень сильная
энергичная фраза которая может изменить
вашу жизнь звучит так я ответственен за
всё что со мной происходит и со мной
происходит только то о чём я думаю с
самого начала Старайтесь управлять
своими мыслями или можно так сказать
если вы даже не можете управлять мыслями
то меньше концентрируется на плохих
мыслей концентрируется на хороших мыслях
всегда растёт то на что вы обращаете
внимание Поэтому если вы обращаете
внимание на хорошие мысли то хорошие
мысли растут А дальше работает правила
хорошую мысль посеешь пожнёшь
действие посеешь хорошее действие
пожнёшь привычку посеешь хорошую
привычку пожнёшь характер посеешь
хороший характер пожнёшь судьбу очень
важно понимать на чём концентрироваться
и понимать и брать ответственность за
всё на себя те люди которые во всём
винят обвиняют других в своих бедах
неудачах и так далее они никогда ничего
не добиваются Как это работает Например
если вы считаете что вы бедны потому что
правительство плохое то зачем вам
меняться это же правительство плохое это
оно должно меняться Если вы говорите что
ваш бизнес не растёт потому что у вас
сотрудники плохие то вам Зачем меняться
это же они плохие они должны меняться
Когда вы берёте ответственность на себя
вы
А тем самым запускаете маховик
саморазвития вы запускаете маховик
изменений Когда вы говорите в том что я
беден виноват я сам и я полностью несу
ответственность за это это сразу
порождает следующий вопрос
а что мне нужно сделать для того чтобы
стать богатым или что мне нужно сделать
чтобы это меня не беспокоило таким
образом Когда вы берёте ответственность
на себя вы запускаете маховик изменений
в своей жизни что бы вы не делали что бы
не происходило в вашей жизни даже молния
не ударяет просто так она ударяет только
в того человека кто оказался в ненужное
время в ненужном месте если во время
грозы вы в доме то молния вас ударить не
может это ваша ответственность Где
находиться в этот момент поэтому каждое
утро Повторяйте эту фразу я ответственен
за то за всё что со мной происходит это
четвёртая фраза которой я хотел бы вам
рассказать вот запомните все эти четыре
фразы каждый день Повторяйте их и я
уверен через год Вы не узнаете себя и
подписывайтесь на мой канал а также вы
можете пройти по ссылке внизу и
подписаться на мой Telegram где я даю
ещё больше историй из своей жизни Из
своего опыта и много лайфхаков